and uh welcome to this meeting of
Executive before we move into the formal
opening of the meeting what I will do is
read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
um
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit the two fire exits
through the partition doors are
currently not in use due to ongoing
Works therefore the fire exits are
through the main doors of the hall or
the storeroom adjacent to the stage the
fire assembly point is the roundabout
Island in front of the main entrance of
the building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff please note that the
meeting will be audio recorded please
switch off mobiles or turn them to
silent toilets and hand washing
facilities are available in the foyer
area
members of the public while you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating uh
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air if you wish
to take photographs or film this evening
I thought there'd be one the clue is
there
um right
um
right
I think none of that is relevant
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording these are all switched
on ready for you to speak so you do not
need to adjust them please make sure
that the microphone is directly in front
of you before speaking members voting
will be done on a show of hands in line
with the Constitution I will ask for a
show of hands four and then against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting alrighty
good
right good evening members good evening
officers and good evening members of the
public uh welcome to this meeting of the
executive today the 9th of November
2022.
we move first of all to item one
apologies for absence and I think
everyone is here on the executive so no
need for any apologies
two non-members attending and looking in
the audience group I can't see any
non-members attending
and that takes us to three minutes of
the meeting held on the 11th of October
2022 members IU agreed that they're an
accurate record and I can sign them
agreed thank you members
right item four is to receive any
Declarations of Interest
do we have any Declarations of Interest
nope okay
um item five questions on notice from
counselors uh members there are none
item six matters referred to the
executive reports from other committees
and they're going there are none
which takes us neatly to item number
seven
which is the um
Quarter Two Financial
2022-23 financial management and
performance update report
I along with assistance from Naomi Lucas
will introduce the report
executive members are asked to note the
quarter two Revenue budget and capital
position set out in sections three and
four of the report and detailed in
appendices one to four
executive members are also asked to note
the quarter two performance position set
out in Section 5 of the report and
detailed in appendix 5.
the latest Revenue budget is 13.1
million pounds changes to the original
budget are due to drawdowns from
reserves which are detailed in appendix
one
the forecast outturn at quarter one is
13.2 million pounds which gives a
projected overspend of 100
000 pounds
the forecasts within the report included
an estimate of increased pay inflation
in
2022-23 which has now been confirmed and
includes other known cost pressures
where this information is available
however it should be noted that there
are Financial risks arising from the
current economic Outlook
which cannot be Quantified with accuracy
at this stage but which are likely to
impact adversely further on the
council's costs of services over the
course of 2022 to 23 and Beyond but
which could not have been foreseen at
the time of the budget being set at the
start of this year
it should also be noted that the
financial position does not yet fully
reflect the cost impact of changes
agreed under the one team strategic
partnership program which is still
subject to change pending agreement of
final arrangements and recruitment to
vacant posts
the variances across individual
portfolio budgets are set out in more
detail in the body of the report and an
appendix too
whilst the council is not currently
anticipating the need to reduce services
in year the financial position will have
to be closely monitored over the rest of
2022-23 in the light of significant
inflationary pressures it is facing
this is likely to make budget setting
for
2023-24 and Beyond even more challenging
than normal
the latest Capital program budget for
2022 23 is 6.4 million pounds
the forecast outturn on the council's
capital program at quarter two is 4.3
million pounds
the major item with slippage against the
revised
2022-23 budget is the asset delivery
program
pending agreement of the stop go
decision point
the table at appendix 3 summarizes the
projected Capital position by service
area
appendix 4 sets out key financial
indicators for the council in more
detail and appendix 5 sets out
performance against the council's other
key performance indicators in more
detail based on the known position at
the end of quarter two
I would like to conclude this report by
saying that Rochford District Council
does not have any borrowing and thus
avoids expensive loan and interest
repayments
it has no Investments and therefore
unlike many other councils avoids these
Associated risks
it is visionary in recognizing the
financial challenges facing local
government by for example the excellent
partnership arrangements with Brentwood
Borough Council with among the many
other benefits that brings through the
creation of a one-team strategic
partnership and shared services approach
and the consequent cost benefits that
that gives us
furthermore we need to press ahead with
cost efficiency by maximizing the use of
our assets
we have a long-standing and proven
history of prudent and responsible
financial management within Rochford
District Council and under my leadership
that will be the continuing theme of our
Administration
members I don't know whether there are
any questions that you wish to ask on
the uh on the report before you tonight
No No Hands Up
in that case I will move to the
decisions being recommended and I'll
read them out at 1.1 and 1.2 that the
quarter 2 2022 stroke 23 Revenue budget
and capital positions set out in
sections three and four below and
detailed in appendices one to four be
noted members are they noted
thank you
and I'll move on to 1.2 that the
half-year performance update at Section
5 and appendix 5 be noted members noted
thank you
we move on to item eight on the agenda
and can I turn to council Williams I
believe in conjunction with
director of communities and health Tracy
Lily to work with each other to
introduce and report and answer any
questions councilor Williams
yeah thank you chairman um
the decision the decision being
recommended
joint cost of living action plan for
Rockford and Brentwood as agreed by the
executive on the 27th of September
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank and can I just interrupt you for a
moment I think we've just got a little
bit of a problem on the sound can you
just project your voice into the
microphone and we just make sure the
sales are could hear me yeah can you
hear me
thank you
thank you chairman the the the decision
being recommended
this evening is for members to review
and note the current version of The
Joint cost of living action plan for
Russian and Brentwood has agreed by the
executive on the 27th of September 22.
thank you and I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank
uh
Tracy for all of the hard work that
she's done and I'd like to hand it over
to Tracy to take this on thank you
thank you
just to provide some update on the
progress that we've made we've now had
the first working group where we
involved our partners which was actually
a really worthwhile experience and quite
heartwarming really they were very
grateful for our support we're now
working on two task and finish groups
one is around developing a comms plan
because I think that's key and like I've
said before we're enablers in this we're
not going to solve the cost of living
crisis so the comms plan is key to that
the other is around data collation so
what the plan is as I've said before at
this executive we will bring back a
dashboard to show the impact of the cost
of living rather than keep bringing the
action plan because it's kind of
irrelevant in a sense the action plan is
for us to to look at and collate
everything that we're doing in terms of
some of the good things that came out of
the working group one of the the things
that was suggested by Essex police was
their involvement in the cost of living
crisis is usually act crisis point when
they're dealing with domestic situations
and one of the things they said would be
really helpful to them is to have a QR
code on their phone that if that
domestic situation was as a result of
financial pressures then they could show
the QR code to that individual or give
them a business card so we're working on
that we're also working on a digital
Campaign which I'm really proud of
actually because one of the the concerns
that's been raised from actually
Brentwood and Rochford is the
communication with our residents and
there have been some requests to do a
leaflet and what I've said I've been
very clear about the leaflet it will end
up looking like an Argos catalog and
it'll be incorrect the minute it's
printed my focus is about making sure we
get the messages out there at the point
and at the earliest possible convenience
so the digital campaign is not about
digital it's about being able to give
that information
to our partners so that we can get it
out there quickly and we're developing
it along a strap line of by your side
and one of those things that we're
trying to do which is key for us is
removing the stigma attached to believe
it or not the cost of living crisis and
one of the concerns is for people that
have never been in crisis before and
have been quite financially stable that
are not going to be financially stable
they might not be able to pay their
mortgage whatever the situation is so
it's just trying to remove the stigma to
say that we are by your side and if you
need any help and support and if it's a
first time situation for you then come
to us and we will provide it for you and
I think that's it we've just developed
the action plan a bit more in terms of
the business support that we can offer
and also we continue to update the web
pages and they've just been updated
today
that's it from me
thank you councilor Williams ably
assisted by director of communities and
health Tracy Lily thank you very much
indeed for that report members any
questions
no
um
we have committed to bringing a report
back to every executive that means every
monthly on monthly basis we're reminding
ourselves of the importance of the
period that we're going through and the
impacts of cost of living I'm
appreciative of that update I thought at
the last full council meeting there was
a very good question and a very good
debate in fact it was a motion but I
thought it was an excellent debate and
reflects the concern that we all have as
individuals to face this corporately
there's an awful lot of good work going
on out there there's quite a bit of
overlap with different agencies in a
desire to be supportive and you and I
Tracy were at the Essex County Council
cost of living Summit on Monday and I
found that quite a reassuring experience
to know that we've actually got out
there along with others and we're at the
Forefront of doing the best just remind
me on our website is is there an easy
press button on the on the front page
for this
I hated it again
to page and then we've got some of the
links to Essex because it's there's more
information from from an Essex
perspective but I just forgot actually
rudely of me um the five thousand pound
that was allocated to the establishment
of warm hubs that's been
um kind of handed out through wraps and
we've already had someone approach us
for that so that's really positive and
what we're doing through that is saying
not only can you make an application to
our fund there's also the Essex fund as
well so that was a real positive right
and that was the 5 000 pound that was
requested in that motion and which we
all unanimously supported and agreed and
I'm pleased that that work has got
underway
um but if you go on to the Rochford
District Council website at the front
page you can click on and I do take your
point that this is such a fast-moving uh
picture it's very very difficult to get
to those people that aren't perhaps
quite as digitally competent but I think
the message has got to be out there that
if we know through the communities that
we rep percent of people that aren't
able then we encourage them to talk to a
relative I'm sure there's someone in the
family that can click on and and get
guidance signposting
um you know unfortunately much as we
would like to we don't have a Magic
Money Tree to solve everyone's uh issues
but what we can do is point to Partners
that can be supportive so thank you very
much indeed for for that report no
further questions
okay in that case I will turn to the
decision being recommended at 1.1 on
page 8.1 and that's for members to
review and note the current version of
The Joint cost of living action plan for
rochwood and Brentwood as agreed by the
executive on the 27th of September 2022.
the great noted
members turning to item nine agenda item
nine I'm going to turn to the chief
executive to update us on item nine
thank you chairman um I'm addressing the
meeting this evening as to reset to
request the item nine as withdrawn of
the agenda this evening and consider
that future meeting the reason for this
has become evident that there's been a
number of questions and errors in the
report that require further information
to reassure members ahead of any
decision being taken
officers who work with members with the
intention of bringing back an updated
report at the earliest for consideration
of December's executive
um I apologize for any inconvenience
this may have caused but it's important
members have all the information in
front of them and time to adjust the
information prior to any decision being
taken
based on the number of questions I've
received ahead of tonight's meeting I
feel it is the this is the case so with
regret I propose that the item be
withdrawn for tonight's gender and
consider it a future meeting of the
executive once additional relevant
information has been added and the
opportunity to engage members further
thank you chairman
thank you chief executive and I would
like to thank you for that statement I
believe with the best of intentions uh
and in a measure to get through the
governor's process in order to proceed
with what is essentially a significant
concept for the uh an opportunity for
Rochford District Council some key
aspects of Engagement and scrutiny have
not yet been thorough and have not taken
place and I believe it is right and
proper and certainly in the light of the
questions that you have been asked I
have been asked to acknowledge that
concern and it is therefore right and
proper to defer this item so that
process can actually happen so members
is that agreed
great
thank you very much thank you to you and
officers for your understanding on that
too
which takes us on to item 10.
and this is the report to the meeting
um under the portfolio of housing assets
and Leisure on the Regeneration strategy
2022-2040 and I turned to councilor Mike
Webb for you to introduce the report
thank you chairman
chairman the council business plan
2020-23 States
we will invest in the future of the
district to stimulate growth and
prosperity as well as attracting
investors and visitors
we will support residents local
businesses and organizations to create a
district full of great life
opportunities and choices business
growth and Economic Security
Jim I'm pleased to be part of a Forward
Thinking Council a council that is
proactive in reaching out to the
community and exploring opportunities
for growth and prosperity
in these uncertain and challenging times
it is right that the council takes the
lead to stimulate regeneration
to that end the council proposes to
develop a regeneration strategy to
support our strategic regeneration
ambition and delivery of the business
plan objectives
with generations of sites in the
district is Central to this ambition and
is ever more important to secure growth
in the local economy and post-pandemic
Recovery
this vision for a regeneration strategy
demonstrates the council's appetite for
taking a proactive role in regenerating
its assets within the district
the primary objective is to support
delivery of the council's social purpose
and strategic regeneration ambitions
I will ensure that the Regeneration
strategy is Community Driven and
delivers positive outcomes for the
community
I also welcome working with executive
members in the drafting of the strategy
as this is such a wide-ranging and
important history issue for our district
and I also intend for A draft copy of
the strategy to go to ons as well and my
thanks to the officers for the work that
they've done behind the scenes in
preparing this work thank you chairman
thank you councilor Webb and I don't
know whether Matt Harwood White's
assistant director assets and Commercial
you wish to add anything
thank you chairman um cancer Webb's
covered that the key points I'll just
reiterate the opportunity the council
has at this time to really lead that
play shaping role or that regeneration
role uh crucially engaging with our
community throughout that process I'll
just highlight that opportunity here and
look forward to working on councilweb
and other members on the Trashy thank
you
thank you very much indeed members are
there any questions following that
introduction
no questions right
um
notwithstanding uh item nine
um which has been withdrawn but when you
actually look at item 10 this is the
exciting part of being in Rochester
District Council and I don't wish to
play Down uh the excellent work in terms
of cutting grass collecting waste
planning Services licensing revenues and
benefits and the Myriad of other things
that we do as business as usual but this
is also about Place shaping and the
opportunity to realize and make
Rochford the district an even better
place in which to live and work so I
really welcome this paper and it sets
the scene for regeneration in the
district so thank you very much indeed
for your presentation and I will turn if
there's no further questions I'll return
to the decision being recommended at
page 10.1 at item one that the emerging
vision for a regeneration strategy to
support the council's Strategic
regeneration ambition and delivery of
the business plan objectives be noted
members is that noted
thank you
I turned to item
11
which is a report to this meeting uh
specifically about section 106 quarterly
briefing
and that's this month's report and turn
to the portfolio for strategic planning
councilor Ian Ward to introduce the
report no doubt ably assisted by the
director of place for the train thank
you very much indeed chairman
um I think if we look at 2.1 that the
simple statement there it is important
that the council routinely monitors its
position with respect to section 106
contributions to ensure that
infrastructure associated with
development can be delivered in a timely
and effective way
all the various
items are in the document
I don't know if there are any questions
that other members wish to ask me but I
have received some questions that I
would like to answer here and now if I'm
hm
right okay you go ahead thank you very
much indeed chairman uh questions that
you've received right
uh it was basically in relationship to
what happens to the education money and
I was asked this specifically because
it's not noted in this particular
document it only contains those items
referred as NHS and those that are
referred to our own that we hold
ourselves
so basically the RDC does not directly
monitor 106 contributions that are
payable to Essex County Council all
section 106 is set out which
contributions are payable to Rochford
District Council and which are payable
to Essex County Council in all instances
Essex County Council is legally the
appropriate body for receiving
contributions relating to County matters
that is education transport sustainables
travel
Etc
Rochford District Council does not
handle these contributions at any point
they are directly transferred from the
developer to Essex County Council and
then spent by Essex County Council on
appropriate capital projects these
capital projects would be agreed through
Essex County council's own internal
governance
Rochford District Council periodically
requests monitoring information from
Essex County Council to include for
example a list of all contributions due
or held by Essex County Council
including their purpose and any refund
date this information will be requested
again and included in a future report
however other than making
representations to Essex County Council
Rochford District Council has no ability
to directly determine how or when these
contributions are spent similarly as its
County Council cannot determine how and
when contributions held by Rochford
District Council are spent thank you
chairman I hope that satisfies the
questions I've received thank you thank
you councilor Ward
any questions for Council award
councilor Belton
foreign
thank you and not not so much a question
but just a thank you for providing this
report in such a user-friendly and
digestible manner previous versions
historically have been quite difficult
to decipher
um and I think we all agree section 106
money as you pointed out at the
beginning of your statement is it's
critical that it gets spent in full and
in a timely manner so just to thank you
for presenting it in such a way that we
can all understand and ensure that we
follow up on
councilor bill
thank you councilor belt and any other
questions or points
councilor FD thank you chairman just a
quick question for Council Ward I know
it's on the report that some of the
money is
indefinite and some has dates on it
can you maybe explain why that is maybe
why are they not all indefinite
I'm going to pass across to my officer
to explain because a lot of the report
was put in by himself
thank you Council water thank you
councilor FD uh it really comes down to
what it says in the relevant section 106
agreement uh you will find that some
section 106 agreements include what we
call clawback Clauses so after a period
of say 10 or 15 years the developer has
a right to ask that money back the logic
being of course that if that money
hasn't been spent in that period of time
then arguably it probably wasn't
required and you'll find that some
section one is six agreements do not
include such clawback Clauses it really
bottoms down to whether or not the
developer specifically requests that
Clause when that agreement's being
drafted and some uh contributions are
just of a nature where
um perhaps because of the purpose
developers might be less inclined to ask
for that money back or or not so it
really it comes down to how that 106
agreement specifically has been drafted
and whether the developer has requested
that Clause be included
thank you
thank you councilor FD any other further
points
no
um well I should have said in the
introduction
um that councilor Ward will be ably
assisted by the uh team leader of
strategic development Daniel Goodman and
thank you very much indeed for for being
here and you got off with it like the
director of place Phil drain because
Daniel was an excellent
explainer of uh of one of the questions
so thank you very much indeed and for
giving up your time this evening thank
you so if there's no no further well
what I am going to say is this is in
part how infrastructure will be
delivered through section 106 funding
and I have used the roundabouts at the
end of roroth Lane and holbridge road
for a long time as fairly simple
infrastructure
at relatively low cost in terms of the
big monies through 106 and a joint
partnership to resolve a huge amount of
traffic congestion so when I hear
residents telling me well we need
infrastructure yes they're absolutely
right I don't disagree with them at all
but this is how in part infrastructure
is delivered at a local level and how we
actually make the lives of residents
much better I along with the rest of you
will have sat in cues for many many
minutes I won't turn it into exaggerate
by saying hours but I've sat for many
many minutes in roethlane waiting to get
through that Junction in the old days
and yet now you just roll up to it and
it just makes the whole congestion there
so much easier so that is an example of
good infrastructure in in the district
and there's other there's other good
examples as well
so um thank you for this report and
turning to page 11.1
item one decision being recommended at
1.1 that the decision on section 106
contributions as at the first of October
2022 be noted members is that noted
thank you very much indeed and thank you
for concisely putting the list which
when I became leader I asked for a
decent list that we could all understand
on 106. as I did on Brownfield site so I
asked for a decent list on Brownfield
sites as well and we've got it now so
thank you Council award for your work on
that right we turn to uh item 12 and I
think it continues to be your lucky
night council award because I think this
is another report for you to introduce
please thank you chairman lucky me
um I am going to introduce
Daniel Goodman again I would like to to
speak after but I believe he wants to to
actually put this local plan assessment
in simpler forms
on a um on the screen so if you'd like
to pay attention I'm going to hand over
to Daniel to go through exactly what is
being presented thank you
thank you Council award uh yes so for
members benefit what we are looking to
do here really is just to go through the
report in um chunks because I appreciate
it's quite a technical report uh and it
probably comes across slightly
duplicative points so
um I thought perhaps going through some
slides might be useful in the sense of
um going through some of the points in
detail
so uh as members will be aware we are
working on a new local plan for the
district we expect that new local plan
to set a 20-year planning strategy
um up to at least the year 2040 and a
transport assessment is clearly a
fundamental component of the evidence
base for that plan
so in simple list terms that I can I can
put forward the transport assessment has
two main roles the first role is to
support the selection of a development
strategy so where new development will
be allowed and the scale of that
development and the way it does that is
it clearly looks at the capacity of the
network as presently exists and it looks
at its ability to cope with that extra
demand
but it also identifies any new
infrastructure needed to make the
network cope if you like so that might
be new Junction improvements or it could
be you know a link Road or it could be
any kind of sustainable transport
solution that might be required
so as I said we're at a key stage at a
local plan and we are looking to
progress now with this more detailed
transport work to support that next
stage so some transport work has already
been done however this was not looking
at the impacts of growth cumulatively
so it's not looking at how 20 years
worth of development might affect the
network it was looking more at whether
individual sites were acceptable in
their own right so there is now that
need for that more technical cumulative
assessment if you like we use the phrase
model based because the way that we
would look to do that is by essentially
looking at a kind of computer-based
system that says this is where in the
district new development might be
located and this is how much and through
some you know clever technical work it
can calculate what that means in terms
of Junction waiting times congestion
levels air quality all those kind of
things and obviously we can then
interpret those outcomes and work out
what's best
so at the meeting of the executive held
on the 13th of July this year and
further to consideration of the issue at
overview and scrutiny in that same month
the executive previously asked for
consultative options to be considered by
the planning policy committee
so the planning policy committee has
considered the issue at its meeting on
the 30th of August and hence why we are
back today reporting on that process
so the summary of those two options the
first option was to work with Essex
County Council to commission the further
phase of work using the counter
council's partner organization Jacobs
the alternative was to Tender for a
third-party consultant to do that work
um and the report which I won't repeat
sets out the potential pros and cons of
both options uh in summary some some
advantages were identified under option
A purely because existing modeling
already exists and so there may be
advantages in terms of time and money in
avoiding that modeling being
um being done again uh and the the
opposite I suppose is true of option b
however the methodology for interpreting
this modeling would be practically the
same and both options are able to meet
the council's technical requirements and
so in that sense
um there is no better or worse option
necessarily from the perspective of its
outputs
um the outcomes under either option
would need to be reviewed by ISIS County
Council as as the local transport
Authority however across the county
um both option A and option b have been
taken by different authorities and
they've both been proven to work
so the planning policy committee were in
favor of option b
um as outlined in the report and option
b just to remind you was to go out to to
the tender exercise
um to appoint a third party consultant
um and the reason given was that it
represented public opinion was taken
into account and provided a good level
of evidence with a Fresh Approach to
trans traffic assessment within the area
and so the planning policy committee
resolved to indicate support for option
b
so that's the end of the slightly brief
than I expected presentation but I'll
just remind members of what the
recommendations in the report were but
I'll hand back over to to council award
to speak now but that's okay
thank you Daniel
um I I think it's important to note that
no matter which consultancy is used
Essex County Council or the highway
Authority and will need to endorse the
assessment undertaken
they will use Jacobs to undertake an
assessment of any third parties
Consultants work and therefore using a
third-party consultant would never be
fully independent of Jacob's involvement
the advantage of using Jacobs directly
is the lower cost and time scales
involved
in being able to access their existing
South Essex model and the need for no
assessment in that third party
consultancy's work
however
there may be advantages in using a
third-party consultancy in the sense
that it may bring two expert opinions
forward that is the third party and
Jacobs and therefore less Reliance on a
single option
therefore
I would like to propose a change
and if I may set it out in a way that I
think we can all understand
so I'd like to revise
1.1 the decision being recommended and I
would like it to read thus
the executive resolves to pursue option
b as set out in this report and
authorize a drawdown of up to two
hundred thousand pounds from the local
development framework Reserve to fund
the assessment noting that option b May
incur additional cost
I would like a second of police
Council of Ward proposing seconded by
councilor FD thank you very much I was
at a hand to speak you're having a
second cancel
thank you chairman I'd like to happy to
support Council Ward's option b in this
and a practical term in this
this is going to last for 20 years
hopefully at least to 2014.
and I sit on the development committee
and sometimes
when the highways opinion comes back and
we feel very strongly that
we disagree it always comes back where
you've got to get another opinion and
this will give us another opinion
so I think this is really good for
future developments we have got two
opinions on this and we're not just
relying on Essex highways so I really
like to help my support for this
thank you if if I can also add that I
would like item 1.2 remaining the same
please no change
thank you
um any other questions uh Council Sperry
thank you chairman
just one question I don't have a problem
with your proposal Council Ward
but could we find ourselves in a in a
patch 22 where we want to take option
B's independent third party
recommendation and Essex don't agree
with it and then play hardball and we
end up in an impasse for
a foreseeable future I don't I mean
don't get me wrong I'm not against your
proposal but I'm just trying to play
devil's advocate here a little bit
um I I think uh I've asked uh Daniel to
look into various things and I've done
so myself
um the connection uh between Jacobs and
ringway Jacobs is is very certain uh the
particular company Jacobs Jacobs UK
limited is a 50 shareholder in ringway
Jacobs as is eurovia which is a 50
shareholder who own ringway so we felt
that it may be better
to have a third party who had no
pecuniary interest
to have a look at it even though Jacobs
will again be assessing as they are the
main representatives for highways within
Essex County Council
thank you councilor Ward you want to add
add to that
fuel drain
thank you chairman uh just in terms of
helping councilor sparing on the
question it's important to remember that
a local plan is a Rochford District
Council document this is evidence-based
for the local plan therefore it is for
the council to make a decision on who
undertakes evidence I think what the
report hopefully sets out is it may take
slightly longer on the basis of gaining
Essex County Council support but
ultimately Essex County Council cannot
block that decision it just
potentially takes slightly longer to
work with them on the outcomes of
commissioning such work
thank you that was helpful councilor
Belton
thank you
um councilor spurring pretty much asked
the question but just to clarify
um once this assessment is done and
becomes part of our local plan
can the highways as the main Authority
and having Jacobs or ringway Jacobs as
their chosen partner could they sort of
veto our views could they sort of
supersede them or stamp out our views
because they're the authority
foreign
thank you chairman thank you Council
bells and I think um
no is the answer
um it becomes a technical conversation
as to whether the consultant has
undertaken things from a technical
standpoint in the correct way and using
the correct assumptions that County
councilors or highways Authority would
then agree with so in essence it removes
Rochford District Council from the
process of undertaking the work because
it becomes an expert independent
consultant's view that is then discussed
directly with Essex County Council my
experience of this is that takes time
and can be quite painful but from the
experience of other authorities doing it
in terms of option A I think it's an
equally painful process so unfortunately
it's um does take time and it is
complicated but the answer is no okay
any other questions
no okay all right so if we turn to the
report itself at page 12.1 we've had a
proposal that uh 1.1 as a recommendation
uh decision uh being recommended be
amended can I ask you Council award
please to read that recommendation again
no certainly
that the executive resolves
to pursue
option b
as set out in this report and authorize
a drawdown of up to 200 000 pounds from
the local development framework Reserve
to fund the assessment noting that
option b May incur additional cost
thank you and my understanding is as
that is a replacement recommendation as
opposed to an amendment we can go
straight to a vote on the replacement if
officers are content with that yeah okay
right in that case can I put that to the
vote is that agreed
unanimous agreement on the part of the
executive and I think if I understood
you correctly councilor Ward you're
leaving proposing leaving 1.2 exactly as
it is uh in which case I'll read that
one out that Authority be delegated to
the director of place in consultation
with the portfolio holder for strategic
planning to manage the delivery of the
assessment reporting into the planning
policy committee members is that agreed
agreed thank you very much again
unanimous now that members concludes
this evening's executive at uh
concluding at 8 14
and I'd like to thank members for your
time this evening thank officers for
your time and thank members of the
public for your time and wish you a very
pleasant rest of your evening thank you
very much indeed and the meeting is
concluded thank you